I thought it would be helpful to talk a
little bit about from where I come the
Media Lab is the center of labs that
shares no content across each other it's
robotics synthetic neurobiology new cars
new toys the the director of the Media
Lab famously calls us the anti
disciplinarians
MIT would maybe say we have no
discipline what we have is unbridled
curiosity and suspended disbelief for
the future so let's see how that plays
out if I said food crisis to you it's
likely that the neighbor sitting next to
you would have a totally different thing
in their mind whether they're talking
about not enough food too much food
agricultural runoff going into oceans
toxic oceans not enough water GMO is the
Savior
GMO is the curse land taken from farmers
they should have land that land was
taken from a rainforest we need more
rainforests there's pollution there's
nutrient nutrition attenuation and
there's urbanization at about this time
you tune out because you're like oh my
god someone needs to solve this please
everybody solve it I try to find
derivatives in my work so this is one of
them how old do you think the average
age of an apple is in the United States
grocery store from the date it was
picked til the data got in your mouth
two months six months 14 months 14
months is the average age of an apple
and by that 14 month old date it's lost
all its antioxidants it's basically a
little ball of cellular sugar and fiber
so the point is we've gotten a little
too big and we're gonna find really
great strategic ways to decentralize
agriculture the next one study of the US
population we've talked a lot about
these things today this is a USDA study
and as you go down the list there are
all things you know and and but there's
one control question they threw in there
I hope it was a control it says
mandatory labels on food containing DNA
thank God
I knew there were smart people in here
okay sometimes nobody laughs and it's
awkward
so 80% of the American population would
support mandatory labels on food
containing DNA so we're a little too big
and we need to admit and rightly so in
the best sense of the word we're much
too ignorant about food so agricultural
revolution has always changed society
and
waise the first one is the reason we're
all here today created society's second
one technology we were doing horse and
plow everything was in the name to
produce more agriculture third one gave
us cities because of the advancements in
vertical integration and biotechnology
biotechnology by the way is squarely a
product of a third agricultural
revolution so the question is what is
the force and if you're as crazy as me
you ask well what if what if things
could be incredibly different what if in
30 years time we had climate democracy
and what I mean is this is a map of the
climates in the world the most
productive and green for agriculture the
least in red Cali if Californian farmers
are now Mexican farmers China's the
largest landholder in brazil the middle
east gets most of its food from where
Western Africa we are slave to climate
in agriculture but what if we could dock
climate and give every country access to
good growing climate it's just a weird
question that I follow up in my work you
remember the scene from Willy Wonka
where they stopped the candy bar and the
things not well it is playing so it goes
through the air it particle eise's it
goes on the other side in a world where
pokemons go can be a five billion dollar
company in five days and not sell
anything based on all the data gets from
you flicking your phone I think we've
reached the point where we can create so
much data about something that we
literally can manifest it in other
places and I'll show you that the last
one I started this work because I went
to Fukushima and in Fukushima
I saw a disaster that reminded me of my
youth and so I started this out of field
really and then I learned that in the
United States only two percent of us are
involved in agriculture the average age
of a farmer is 58 it doesn't stop there
I spoke with Kofi Annan and he said to
me 50% of the population of Africa under
80% don't want to be farmers they've
seen the life of their parents their
grandparents struggle they've left
they've moved into the city this
continues on all over the world I got to
speed up a lot so we got to make
movements we've seen KOTOR movement
we've seen maker movement we're in the
middle of networked movement the next
movement squarely on the scene is food
movement but it what it means is access
to biology in the same way HTML gave us
access to the Internet in the same way
Linux gave us access to the Internet or
Mozilla we're going to be looking for
new to
so this was a tool we worked on
developing a while ago now and it's cool
technology and it was really fun but the
most interesting thing to me was that
once a month we'd have a harvest in the
middle of the media lab bright white
roots deep green colors is this a new
grocery store model a new cafeteria
experience it was one thing for sure the
first time anyone in the media lab have
ever ripped the roots off of anything we
get our salad in bags and that's okay
but this inspired robot Isis algorithms
experts computer scientists to see what
they could do for food we also learned
something very interesting I would
harvest the food and I would I would
take it back if there was some leftover
and the next day it would be incredibly
sweet so what I learned is that plant
was reacting in one day's time
biochemically to create a flavor
difference so I built a lab and inside
of that lab I was studying climate
everything about it 30 points of Network
sensing per plant if you know that
genome we're talking about the phenome
or the phenomena that surrounds it that
creates an expression when you say I
love that tomato and Tuscany on the
north slope with the cow next door
that's happy and the chicken you love
the expression of biochemicals that that
caused in a plant there's more flavorful
or nutritious for you so inside of this
lab we've been studying that we create
climate recipes that's the blue line
unfortunately all those zigzaggy lines
are all my sensors right now I'm trying
to conform them to the recipe but
imagine that that was 1982 Napa and I'm
going after the perfect Cabernet that's
exactly what we're doing so we call this
the plant Facebook this is one of my
labs on the facade of the Media Lab and
inside of that we've been experimenting
with all kinds of things we've reduced
the water consumption in the growing of
food by about 90% using a technology
that was developed originally by NASA
for Mir Space Station we also grow about
5 times faster than you can do
conventionally and lucky it lucky enough
in Boston 365 days a year when it's
snowing most interesting thing that I've
grown they asked I'll tell you
partnership was small forward seedbank
I got some tomatoes that hadn't been
grown in industrial in 150 years I'm the
only person in this room that's ever
tasted those Tomatoes we have a
diversity of genetic information in this
world that we are not even close to
tapping into you'll never know what that
tastes like if it was better for you but
we will start to now because if you're
not up
amazing for an uncontrolled environment
perhaps you're optimizing for the flavor
and nutrition in your food these
environments are expensive so I started
building smaller ones to get them to go
all over the place we call this the
personal food computer it's in the vein
of the 1970s hacker clubs for computers
we actually have a homebrew food
Computer Club we put these out in
schools and I developed a game for kids
and I said okay here's your virtual
environment
there's your sensors there's your
actuators you load a recipe that some
other kid grew anywhere in the world put
in the plant start running it but then
they get curious they're like why do
plants need co2 co2 is bad right climate
change is awful so crank down the co2
plant dies kid learns a lesson but
learns it because he was just he or she
was just curious
so put that out in classrooms across
everything from first grade to 12th
grade and I'll tell you I don't have
enough time to tell you how awesome it
was they created climates of the past
they created climates of the present and
they projected climates of the future in
their classrooms if you're trying to
teach a kid about climate change pretty
powerful when they can have one in the
palm of their hand and decide that this
was the first time they ever thought
they might want to be a farmer so we put
a new version of that out at the White
House a few weeks ago personal food
computer version - it's awesome check it
out this is the lab I'm building now at
MIT I'm going to start going really fast
okay
all the data that we're collecting
people ask how do you know how good it
is we're running this data every eight
seconds things like temperature humidity
light onto all of the minerals that go
in the water I unpacked the word terroir
to mean something to science so we study
that we then culture and secrets the
root micro biomes to see what bacteria
what microbes are inside what's making
that plant amazing we take the plant
forward we do GCMs and mass spec we get
down to all of the chemical compounds
that that plant has to present we're
even using things like computer vision
we tie it all together to 303 million
data points per plant per grow we take
that forward I know I'm losing most of
you machine learning machine learning
and artificial intelligence to figure
out hey how can we do the best for the
technology that's already locked in that
plant we call that open phenome it
applies to all of the research going on
right now of collecting data in fields
in Ag lastly
that the farmer of the future growing
Ebola open source and I have to mention
our community
so I'll click through quickly but what
we've done in the last six months is
create on 20 countries in six continents
nerd farmers of the future sharing their
data we've put that data in a data trust
it will never be sold it will always be
available for scientific advancement
that's not the future this is let's do
it thank you
[Applause]